to introduce our speaker tonight we have
a senior from Cincinnati Ohio majoring
in political economy the opinions page
editor of the collegian give it up for
Jack Butler good evening everyone I'd
like to be able to question I don't have
a door prize sorry but my question is do
any of you know how long the Patient
Protection Affordable Care Act or
Obamacare is anyone mmm that's a good
you know what I'll let that be the best
answer because the final pass statute
itself runs only about a thousand pages
so that's like the Affordable Care Act
the text of it but versions of the bill
ran upwards of 2,000 pages during the
debate in drafting which is white the
2700 figures correct in some sense but
more important as a as long ago as 2013
there have been depending on how you
count around 30,000 page of his pages of
association associated regulations
issued which is a lot a couple years ago
Mitch McConnell had a big stack of those
regulations he was showing it off
reading the act itself proved too much
for justices of the Supreme Court in
2012 when they heard a case on Obamacare
constitutionality asked by an Obama
administration lawyer during hearings if
the court could go through the whole Act
and determine which parts were
unconstitutional Justice Antonin Scalia
wondered what happened to the Eighth
Amendment in case you were asleep during
Constitution 101 the Eighth Amendment
prohibits cruel and unusual punishment
but if we were to defend liberty and to
know what such odious pieces of
legislation truly contained somebody has
to subject himself to this punishment
now I actually asked Joseph Rago if he
had read all of Obamacare he said most
of it but I doubt he's read all 33,000
or so pages of Obamacare related text
but his writing even so has demonstrate
a better understanding and knowledge of
it than just about any other pundit
today
a 2005 Dartmouth college graduate with a
history degree Joseph ragout joined The
Wall Street Journal that same year as an
assistant editorial features editor and
now serves as a member of its esteemed
editorial board in 2010 he was a media
fellow at Stanford University's Hoover
Institution and 2011 he became one of
the youngest ever winners of the
Pulitzer Prize earning recognition for
his wall crafted against the grain
editorials challenging the health care
reform advocated by President Obama
specifically he won the prize for a
string of editorials from December to
April 2010 when and just after Obamacare
was being debated in Congress that
dissected and showed the flaws and its
various components and ultimately
demonstrated that stripped of its
illusions Obamacare is really about who
commands the country's medical resources
as he wrote on the eve of Obamacare his
passage in 2010 but he's not just a
health care long he is also written for
the journal on many other subjects
including most recently wisconsin
Governor Scott Walker the Islamic state
Republican resurgence in New England and
Dartmouth fraternity life among other
things for the writings of a relatively
young journalist to exude such breath
and expertise simultaneously is truly a
sight of immense promise perhaps sunday
has output my equal in volume the amount
of Obamacare related regulations and if
not he'll certainly be more ride widely
bred at any rate please join me in
welcoming Joseph Raghu
thank you for the kind introduction
thank you to Hillsdale for the
hospitality and definitely thanks to all
of you for turning out on a Thursday
night before I talk about the Patient
Protection and Affordable Care Act
Obamacare if I can use that term and
play polite company and I not sure I
would have done the same as an
undergraduate so I appreciate it and
it's because health policy can be
somewhat dry a little bit tedious at
times and I promise to try not to bore
you and in any rate to make this talk a
little bit shorter and less arduous than
a Hillsdale bus trip to Washington and
so I want to say a word or two about
what to do about Obamacare and the one
thing I hope to convince you of tonight
is that health care is at the center of
American politics and it has to be we've
got about a hundred million people who
are covered by taxpayers taxpayers by
about 1.2 trillion dollars worth of
health care every year and that's before
Obamacare has really kicked in we spend
as an economy about one of six dollars
on health care and that's headed to one
of five if healthcare was a separate
economy it would be the size of France
the sixth largest in the world and if
you're a conservative and you wonder why
conservative Republicans haven't been
able to reduce the size of government
well one reason is the government is an
insurance company that also has a
standing army so if you can't do
something about health care it's very
hard to reduce government and if you're
a liberal wondering I don't know if
there's any in the audience but if you
if you want say more redistribution in
the name of
come in equality it's it's hard to do
because we're already spending so much
on health care and if you're wondering
why American politics are so angry and
so polarize and so dysfunctional I think
one reason is Obamacare and this is a
law that set the political tone for the
Obama presidency it was crammed through
Congress on a partisan majority without
really any kind of rough national
consensus an entitlement the country
didn't want and couldn't afford that
continues to haunt us to this day and
it's bad I think politically for both
parties in the sense that Republicans
can't get rid of it and Democrat and
Democrats can't fix it but all that
being said I should say confessing my
own biases that I'm the one person I can
say unreservedly and confidently who has
benefited the most from Obamacare I like
to call it the Joe Eigo lifetime
employment act and when the Speaker of
the House as we all remember says we
have to pass the bill to find out what's
in it that's really a winning Powerball
ticket for a journalist so I I can say
that I have benefited but I also want to
talk tonight about how the politics of
health care are maybe changing and why
this might be the moment that some of
the problems before Obamacare created by
Obamacare and what might be solved after
Obamacare in a way that leave us a
richer and fair and ultimately healthier
country these changes have to do with
the presidential race coming up
especially with a Supreme Court case
that's going to be argued next week and
I'll talk about a little bit but I do
want to say that really there are
emerging and genuine reform alternatives
that could fix some of the problems and
perhaps even more amazingly have a
chance this time
Washington now as we get started you
really can't understand the Affordable
Care Act unless you understand
healthcare politics and in this case
those begin in 2009 we've got a young
new president who's been elected
seemingly in repudiation of the old one
from previous Party Democrat swept into
power with huge super majorities
Republicans couldn't stop a swinging
door in Great Society days we're here
again in David Axelrod's new book his
memoir of the Obama presidency
he recalls when the president was told
he just won the Nobel Peace Prize and
mr. Obama responds well that's great but
I just really like to pass the health
care bill I don't know whether that says
something about the Nobel Peace Prize or
President Obama's qualifications for it
maybe both
but it does give you a sense of the
feeling at the time and President Obama
I think what this plan was joining a
debate that we've had in the country
since about the days of Harry Truman and
as different as left and right are on
health care they've all kind of agreed
for all these years on one thing and
that it's that the US has a free-market
health care system for liberals this is
a problem that needs to be overcome it's
something that needs to be fixed and for
conservatives it's been for many years
of virtue to defend and we saw that in
this debate of course critics called the
law too costly too destructive bad for
economic growth those were the more
charitable comments but sometimes even
called it on American and from my
perspective that's not really it it's
that the law is too American it's not a
rupture or a discontinuity but it's
really an acceleration of a half-century
of progress from markets to government
and health
from competition to consolidation and
from liberty to government control it's
a larger transfer of power it's a it's a
jump in this progression it's unlike
anything we've seen since 1965 but it's
really the same approach that we saw
under george w bush under bill clinton
under george HW bush even ronald reagan
all the way back to LBJ so here's how it
always works in Washington people
identify some problem in health care and
they say here's the solution here's the
thing that will solve the problem once
and for all
that solution passes and it inevitably
fails the next generation says well we
need a solution for the solution
resulting in another failure a solution
for the solution for the solution and so
on in an endless recursive loop so what
do I mean by that well here's here's the
first item today doctors and hospitals
use a system they're called CPT codes
there's about 14,000 of them and they
use these codes whenever they perform a
medical procedure to bill the government
or bill an insurance company for
something they've done right now we're
expanding that it's called ICT 10 and
we're going from about 14,000 codes to
140,000 and they're meant to catalogue
everything the medicine could possibly
achieve everything that doctors could
possibly do so there will now be 72
codes for injuries due to birds bitten
by a parent struck by a parent contact
with parent then it repeats with ducks
because geese turkeys chickens and a
category other fowl
there are codes for injuries sustained
in opera houses art galleries squash
courts and mobile homes there is a code
for people who spend too much time in a
deep freeze refrigerator though not too
much time because there is also a code
for death there are codes for walked
into a lamppost initial encounter walked
into a lamppost subsequent encounter
that is walked into a lamppost
more than once there is a category
burned due to water seized on fire I'm
not making this up now you could say
maybe this new iteration is more
accurate maybe but it's really
complexity taken to the point of
absurdity and beyond this is what we've
always seen in healthcare the difference
with Obamacare is that what we were told
President Obama said you can expect
superior scientific and technical
technocratic leadership from President
Obama and and his allies the spirit of
the age was that all healthcare
decisions are too important and too
complex to be left to ordinary citizens
to ordinary patients and the Godin
conceit of the law is that medicine
should be even more ruled by experts who
are dis allegedly disinterested
dispassionate rational post ideological
pragmatics who will follow reason
wherever it will lead and the truth of
what and find the truth of what works
and what doesn't and what I argue is
that this is not new we've tried this
for a long time since Medicare and
Medicaid were created in 1965 we
instantly had health cost explosion so
what the Jimmy Carter Administration
said was well we just need price
controls on hospitals and that will
solve the problem
Ronald Reagan of all people continued
the work
created something known as the
prospective payment program which
consolidated the Carter price controls
into 746
distinct diagnosis these diagnosis
related groups continue to this day in
1998 and during the Clinton later during
the Clinton administration we tried to
refine the diagnosis related groups it
was professor at Harvard and this is
fodder for the theory that Harvard can
ruin anything an economist at Harvard
William cell decided that what Medicare
really needed was a better formula he
called it a relative value scale it's
supposed to measure not only what
doctors do but the time ever judgment
skill and stress of fixing these
problems entails and now this formula is
now applied to about 7,000 physician
services so it's a it's a problem that
didn't begin with Obamacare but it's a
problem that Obamacare amplified
increased and and the results have been
predictable in in nineteen sixty two we
spend about 6% of the economy on health
care there abouts now it's 17% and as I
mentioned going up to twenty percent by
the end of the decade Medicaid
Medicare's unfunded liability which is
the gap between the benefits that we
have promised to people who pay taxes
and the taxes we have levied to pay them
it's about thirty one trillion dollars
over the next 75 years about the life of
someone born today now thirty one
trillion dollars is a number beyond
human comprehension but what the Obama
people who came in said this is the
problem we inherited but no no no we're
smarter we know better this time we'll
do it right the old price controls have
failed we just need better price
controls and it's a version of an old
joke which is that the soup is terrible
and the portions are too small so now
with this law and I think this is really
the worst feature of it it's price
controls on steroids where the
government decides to pay more for
treatments if the government determines
are more valuable to pay less for
treatments that they decided are
wasteful to encourage physicians to
practice this way right
rather than that way it takes insurance
and it defines what insurance is uses
public power to compel consumers to buy
that defined product it imposes price
controls on how much insurance should
cost now at least the best you can say
about this method is that it's
economically consistent in our world of
infinite wants and finite resources
there are really only two ways to
allocate any good or service either
through prices and the decisions of
millions of individuals or else through
central planning and political
discretion this choice is inexorable and
we got more of the latter the problem I
think and is that it closes off the
other options the things we haven't
tried it inhibits decentralization
competition innovation creativity
evolution and learning and this is a
problem that's really culminating in
Obamacare but it didn't begin there it's
as I said it accelerates the march to a
state driven system but it did not
originate with it and for that I think
you have to go back to the original
since the original policy choices the
original solutions that that inspired
all the other solutions that I mentioned
earlier and there are two things here
one is employer sponsored insurance we
joining the World War 2 era we imposed
wage controls on private employers but
we decided to exempt healthcare benefits
that means that all employers sponsored
surance is offered tax-free but wages
are taxed still to this day and what
it's led to is employers paying their
workers more in benefits and less in
take-home pay and people who buy health
insurance on their own aren't entitled
to the same benefits they have to use
after-tax dollars this is not very good
for the self-employed for small
businesses for entrepreneurs and for a
lot of other people and like the company
store this inefficient and
equitable preference encourages workers
to be paid in kind rather than cash
and the third party payment system it
created has an pivoted competition and
eliminated very often even private price
tags in medicine we encourage most
normal middle-class Americans about a
hundred fifty million of us to launder
their incomes through the health care
system rather than making their own
trade-offs I think between health care
and everything else the other problem is
the entitlement state and it begins with
Medicare this is called fee-for-service
where in the traditional program any
doctor or hospital a patient visits is
paid a lump sum one of those price
controls one of their codes and the same
arbitrary fee schedule applies to the
best Hospital and to the worst hospital
to the best doctor and the worst doctor
regardless of the quality of the quality
or the value of the care that they
deliver providers who find a way to
deliver better results at lower costs
aren't rewarded like they would be in
any other engine industry and it makes
perfect sense that this is lasted for so
long for this half-century entitlements
the best way to understand them is as an
ocean of money surrounded by people who
want some and their incentive is always
to increase the amount we spend increase
the size of the ocean rather than
providing a better answer and the
problem here this this whole system has
arisen because liberals think of health
care they can conceive of health care as
some fixed things some commodity that
can be defined you know we've got the
codes there's a code for that and what
they've denied is that prices are signal
that includes an incentive and they're
most valuable in in a field like
medicine a field that's highly complex
highly dynamic where the evidence
changes constantly
medical progress new in better ways of
extending and improving lives new
understandings of the enormous
variability of human disease of biology
and of patient preference so what we I
think what we need to do is we need to
give consumers the incentive to save
money and providers and insurers the
freedom and the information that they
need to conceive of other options and
the healthcare economy can work just
like any other part of American industry
and we haven't done this we haven't done
it for so long and it explains I think
everything people don't like about the
current system and it's not just the
ever rising costs its it's everything
it's the unfathomable hundred thousand
dollar bill for a sprained ankle it's a
doctor who doesn't use email it's
grandma's eight specialists who aren't
even aware of each other's existence why
is health care conducted via pad and pen
and still to this day often beepers and
fax machines in the iPhone era why for
example are there so few geriatricians
when so many people are now turning 65
why can't I get a price for an MRI why
can't we find any usable and meaningful
information about prices and quality so
that's that's the larger problem but I
want to talk about a political problem
which is that Republicans have often
been slow I think to recognize some of
these realities broad conservative
interest in health care as I said has
mainly taken the form of opposing
liberal attempts to take over the system
rather than putting forward credible
ideas of their own and this isn't to say
that no one on the right was interested
or that the think tanks didn't have
their white papers but there was never
any real mass appeal health care has
never been like tax reform
or gun rights or immigration or national
security judges I mean you can go down
the list and you don't historically you
haven't revved up a crowd by saying
let's equalize the tax treatment of
health insurance it is not exactly an
inspiring rally cry and politics like
nature abhors a vacuum
and so while Republicans vigorously
opposed Obamacare they rarely put
forward a plan of their own there were a
few things there was things like medical
malpractice reform but nothing really
commensurate with the pre-existing
conditions that were around prior to
Obamacare now since the law passed
they've opposed and I give them credit
for doing so but they've done so on a
platform of repeal and replace they've
said we're gonna repeal the law and
replace it with something better so
repeal and replace repeal and replace
but they've never released or come to
even a rough consensus about a
replacement and that really is what's
changing the debate is being joined not
in this positive negative sense but as
to constructive or these positive plans
for the future of health care and I
can't say it's because Republicans read
The Wall Street Journal editorial page
and take our advice it's really because
of a Supreme Court case it's called King
versus Burwell and it's going to be
argued next week on Wednesday a decision
is expected in June and this is a case
that involves no great questions of
constitutional interpretation the
question at the heart of the case really
is is Obamacare a law or not in other
words what the plaintiffs are asking is
for the High Court to uphold the
Affordable Care Act as it was written
and instruct the administration to
faithfully execute the plain language of
the statute that President Obama passed
excuse me the Congress passed and
President Obama signed and if you look
at Obamacare or at least the version
that passed Congress in 2010 the law
instructed the states to establish these
insurance exchanges and if they didn't
the administration was empowered to
create a federal fallback exchange in
those states the law quote says that the
subsidies will only be available to the
people who enroll through an exchange
established by the state and the
question in king is whether these
taxpayer subsidies can be distributed
through the federal exchange as well as
the administration insists now if we go
back to the debate people were not
really paying attention to the details
they were only paying attention to the
Apollo to the politics but the record as
it exists is that this decision was no
accident
Democrats among themselves were divided
over the structure of the exchange
liberals favored some kind of national
clearinghouse some of the more moderate
Democrats favored state control these
specialists one out and condition the
subsidies on the state-based exchanges
now there are constitutional reasons for
doing this as well the federal
government cannot commandeer the
sovereign states under the Constitution
so what they wanted to do is create
whether they knew it or not an incentive
for governors to participate voluntarily
if they if the governors didn't
participate by taking the quit of the
exchanges they would be denying their
voters the quo of eligibility for what
could turn out to be billions of dollars
worth of benefits but I think Democrats
also miscalculated they were convinced
that opposition to Obamacare would melt
away that Americans would learn to love
the law and that did not happen
36 states now - 37 either opted out of
the State established exchanges or they
failed to make the arduous regulatory
dead
so here the administration this is about
2012 faced three choices they could obey
their own law deny subsidies to the
two-thirds of the population that lives
in states with a federal exchange and
then thus greatly diminish President
Obama's legacy project what is health
care they could also number to go to
Congress for a legislative fix but they
didn't do that as a result of the sort
of political estrangement that continues
to this day and they had a third option
which is the one they took which is that
they could improvise a workaround what
they did was they through an IRS rule
they rewrote the law and simply declared
that the subsidies be available on the
federal exchanges to essentially
declaring the federal government as the
51st state now will the supreme court
overrule the subsidies the joke I like
to use is that it will be a 5-4 decision
in matters such as this this this is
really not a as I said a constitutional
question legislative intent is
irrelevant and matters in matters of
statutory interpretation what controls
is the plain meaning of the words of the
law and here the text is clear it's
consistent it's tightly worded it says
subsidies in state-based exchanges only
on the other hand the question is
politically and legally fraught the
administration has kind of a rotisserie
of arguments for why the supreme court
should reject the challenge some claim
it's merely a drafting error others say
that the statute has to be interpreted
in the context in terms of its larger
purposes and in tents which was to
provide allegedly universal health care
if you're looking for my exact guess I
think what they're going to do is throw
the matter back to Congress and say stop
bringing your problems to us you fix
this political branches get us out of it
but I think it will be a close-run thing
the what's really concentrating minds in
Washington however is the possibility of
overturning the federal subsidies and
it's scrambling the politics of health
care and maybe convincing the
Republicans to operate to adopt a more
coherent approach if the Supreme Court
forces washing Washington to reopen the
law by turning down the subsidies the
question Republicans really need to
answer is whether they're going to solve
the problems the Democrats created or
simply allow the Obamacare damage to
grow and I think this is a really
interesting debate it's an urgent
challenge to those of us who oppose the
law and especially to avoid a disaster
of our own making and things right now
have broken out kind of into three
schools three repeal and replace schools
the First's are people who think that
repeal is at this point pretty
unrealistic but think that Obama care
can be kind of fixed at the margins may
be massaged in the center and Obama care
can be reformed to move health care in a
more free market direction the second
group are people who think the law can
be repealed but only if we're publicans
have a credible alternative so this is
kind of the traditional repeal and
replace school and the third which is a
growing group right now there are people
who think the law can be repealed
entirely that we can return to the
pre-obama care status quo ante and if
the Supreme Court does part of the dirty
work that's fine with us we don't need
to do anything
in response this is a group of
Republicans who excuse me were inspired
in a lot of ways to join politics as a
result of the Affordable Care Act they
were elected in 2010 and then in 2014
and they they've created some of the
major train wrecks for Republicans in
recent years I'm thinking of the
government shutdown of last year the
current impasse perhaps over immigration
funding and these Republicans who want
the judicial rapture to arrive what they
say is look Obama care has never been
popular
if the subsidy foundation of the law is
undermined the rest will collapse of its
own weight and there's there's a
regulatory quirk a lot of the subsidies
mandates and taxes are conditioned on
each other so if the subsidies are
repealed so will all the rest of it and
more people will be helped
than will be harmed if those are
withdrawn now my view my own view is
that they're under estimating the
economic political and media blowback
from overturning the subsidies in the 36
or 37 states you can always say that the
White House should have avoided the
problem by not handing out illegal
subsidies but the public may not notice
and may not care about that difference
once the people who are on Obama care
can suddenly no longer afford to do so
excuse me
one thing to understand is that inside
of Obama care plans are embedded all
kinds of other political goals that have
nothing to do with the universal
coverage part of it is income
redistribution part of it is to convert
insurers into utilities and that's
raised the price of Obama care policies
these subsidies are meant to counteract
that to make them artificially cheap if
they're withdrawn about five million
people at this point potentially
10 million going forward would be
exposed the true cost of President
Obama's agenda and may not be happy
about it and I think what could happen
is you can see a replay sort of a bad
flashback of the if you like your health
plan you can keep your plan if you like
your head your doctor you can keep your
doctor except only in Reverse this time
with the Republicans accused of denying
care to the sick the other thing that
will happen is that President Obama will
demand that congressional Republicans
simply pass a one-sentence bill
restoring the subsidies on the federal
exchanges if they refuse without an
answer of their own the public may
conclude that they share the blame this
week the White House said that they have
no backup plan no plan B whatsoever if
the subsidies are struck down I think
that's a little bit silly I think they
do have these backup plans but what
they're trying to do is increase
pressure on Congress what they're also
trying to do is force Republican
governors to join the federal exchange
they will come under tremendous pressure
from the insurers and the hospitals that
have spent five years adopting adapting
excuse me to the Affordable Care Act and
they'll also come under pressure from
their own constituents denied benefits
now some of them would resist for a time
just like they did on joining Obama
cares new Medicaid program but I don't
think they'll do so for very long and
what that what happens in that case is
that you'll end a bipartisan gloss to
the Affordable Care Act that it's never
had you have Republican governors who
are giving it new legitimacy in
Washington also alienating their own
voters at home and this will be a big
political problem and it's really the
most interesting fissure right now
in conservative politics the far better
alternative in my view to avoid some of
these problems is for Republicans to
respond to President Obama's ultimatums
with their own proposals he won't agree
to anything that repeals ordy funds or
cripples his signature achievement but
it'll also need something from Congress
and it's never really been in that
position before since since Republicans
took over and so the the immediate GOP
goal should make it should be to make
insurance cheaper so people don't need
so much of a subsidy to obtain insurance
and this means essentially deregulating
the exchanges plank by plank lift the
regulations lift the taxes devolve to
the states more of a role in controlling
their own insurance market the private
market will gradually heal and prices
will fall you can say to the liberal
states that prefer Obamacare
command-and-control if you like your fed
if you like your state-based exchange
you can keep it here's what we're going
to do instead of forcing consumers into
the Washington design plans that now are
sold on the exchanges now in return I
think Republicans can offer to restore
some of the subsidies for for the White
House maybe smaller maybe in the form of
a fixed tax credit for people who again
don't benefit from the tax preference
for employer and sponsored insurance and
this would really be a down payment on a
larger reform that would happen after
President Obama leaves office you
essentially create a holding pen and
throw this entire debate into the 2016
presidential race were the candidates
from both parties I think would would be
forced in this case to have an
instructive debate about their vision
for a post Obama care world now the good
news is that the smarter Republicans are
headed in that direction this month we
saw Orrin
of the Senate Finance Committee and fred
Upton of the House Energy and Commerce
Committee these are the ones with
jurisdiction over health care they've
come to consensus that they're trying to
send to their members you can also
expect to see on Tuesday a plan from
Paul Ryan and some other House
Republicans that is very much worth
watching and the real challenge will be
to come to a consensus around one of
these alternatives now this won't
satisfy everyone on the right some think
we can revert to a free-market paradise
one I don't think ever existed and they
think know that nothing literally
nothing is better than Obamacare light
and this to me will become one of the
most fascinating presidential debates in
a long time and one way to tell the
difference between a candidate with a
substantive agenda a substantiative
reform agenda and those who were just
posturing and one thing I guess I would
say is that the American political
system as as you're thinking about this
in your own way valuating the candidates
one thing is that the American political
system is supposed to make change hard
it's supposed to be incremental it's
supposed to be slow it's supposed to be
evolutionary and one reason that
Obamacare is so bad is that it violates
these norms it's a dramatic and
convulsive change in a way that the
American political system was never
designed to accommodate so when you
consider the ambitions of the
Republicans and there are so many of
them running for the White House the
serious ones I think will be the ones
who say that we can turn around the
battleship slowly move from
consolidation to competition from
government to Liberty from central
planning to markets
I think they'll also recognize that
voters tend to like both Republican and
Democratic ideas and can reasonably ask
why can't we combine the best from both
sides more coverage from Obamacare more
market-based alternatives from
Republicans we haven't seen this in
politics but I think there's an opening
for a candidate to succeed who can who
can offer a more realistic more
pragmatic alternative that could
potentially appeal to members of both
parties now this isn't hell politics is
operated in the Obama era but luckily we
are beginning a new one the candidate I
think who succeeds will restore markets
try to restore markets to healthcare as
I said turn the battleship around
convince voters that they should have
more control over their own health care
dollars rather than the federal
government and this would be an
experiment unfortunately one that we
have never tried and so I hope we're
about to do so I think there are reasons
for optimism and that's all I have to
say about that I'm happy to answer any
questions you may have
sure
no I'm trying to convince them to offer
one but I think I think you will see
some some real substance from the
candidates this year I think it'll be a
policy heavy debate so far the only
candidate with a plan is bobby Jindal
it's at least he has a plan which is
more than anyone else can say but it's
really firmly in the do-nothing camp
it's saying don't try to compromise
don't come up with an alternative let's
hold firm let's fight and I don't think
he's gonna get a lot of traction with
that but I'm always happy to be proven
wrong
yeah I think it would definitely be a
step forward at least at first once you
start to get a cascade of bad politics
stemming from that I think you could
move even faster in the other direction
so on day one I I would be thrilled
after that I'm afraid Republicans will
once again become the dog that caught
the car and don't know what the heck to
do with it
and I mean I was just in Washington on
Tuesday and there really is kind of a
panic setting in it's among all the the
three groups I recognize I mean there
it's they are truly worried about what
would happen and I don't think I talked
to anybody who was thrilled that this
case is going forward except for maybe
the two scholars who kind of developed
this case one is Michael cannon of the
Cato Institute the other is Jonathan
Adler of Case Western University and one
has legal training one Michael cannon
has a ton of health care training and
they they really generated this case I
wonder if they're not going to have a
hangover as a result
sure well I started covering healthcare
completely by accident I I started the
journals an intern in 2005 and soon
thereafter was brought over to start
writing editorials and they needed
someone to write about healthcare so at
that point it was just kind of dutifully
file stories that never go anywhere had
I known what President Obama's election
ultimately would have meant at least for
me I might have voted for him but yes as
I said I just I really lucked out and
happened to be at a great institution
writing about an important topic in an
important time and and I'm pretty
grateful that yet those moons align